y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar hoy de acuerdo
con la organización panamericana de la
salud más de la mitad de la población
del continente americano ha recibido el
esquema completo de vacunación contra el
jove 19 es decir estamos hablando de más
de
550 millones de personas la mayoría
están concentradas en 20 de los 35
países que componen el continente
americano vamos a hablar de colombia
este país comenzó a exigir la
presentación de un pasaporte sanitario
para poder acceder a lugares públicos de
alta afluencia de personas la medida
generó todo tipo de opiniones tendremos
reportes desde la ciudad de bogotá y
también en la ciudad de río de janeiro
en brasil reportaron esta semana 0
pacientes hospitalizados por kobe 19
como no lograron vamos a conversar con
nuestra corresponsal en esta ciudad
brasileña para tener más detalles y en
nuestra consulta con el doctor pérez
hablaremos de los resultados de varios
estudios realizados realizados que
evidencian que el consumo de un
antidepresivo puede ayudar a evitar la
hospitalización en pacientes que ya
tienen kobe 19 otros estudios también
evidencian los ciervos son portadores
del virus sars cop 2 es decir el
coronavirus o el virus que produce el
kobe 19 también el doctor pérez nos
hablará de su nuevo libro que está
precisamente relacionado con la pandemia
del cob el 19 pues comenzamos y lo
hacemos como siempre haciendo una
actualización de las cifras del cierre
de la semana hacemos un panorama de cómo
está avanzando la pandemia de kobe 19 en
nuestro continente vamos a ver algunas
de las cifras tengo algunos territorios
poco habituales por ejemplo groenlandia
si esta isla pertenece a dinamarca pero
geográficamente es parte de américa de
nuestro continente en groenlandia han
reportado poco más de 1100 casos y 0
fallecidos desde que comenzó la pandemia
de kobe 19 nos vamos ahora hasta el
caribe república dominicana reporta más
de 339 mil casos están próximos ya a
llegar a los 340 mil de los fallecidos
ya superan los 4 mil 100 en perú
contabilizan 2.2 millones de casos un
poco más de 2.2 los fallecidos superan
los 200 mil en paraguay cierran esta
semana con más de 400 dos mil casos han
fallecido en este país suramericano más
de 16 mil 300 personas y terminamos en
las islas malvinas en el sur de nuestro
continente en donde han reportado 79
casos de kobe 19 y 0 víctimas
y vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo y
asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta doctor bienvenido como siempre
es un gusto conversar con usted hoy
vamos a hablar de estudios y un estudio
reciente demuestra que un antidepresivo
que es de hecho de muy bajo costo reduce
la necesidad de tener que llevar al
hospital a los pacientes que ya tienen
kobe 19 qué información hay al respecto
es muy importante esta información
porque son medicamentos primero que
están disponibles en cualquier parte del
mundo que hay presentaciones genéricas
que son medicamentos accesibles lo que
hacen estos medicamentos es que bloquean
unos receptores que impiden la
inflamación y la liberación de las
citoquinas en la respuesta por kobe
estos estudios se llevaron a cabo en
durante varios meses y se encontró una
reducción tanto de las complicaciones
como de la hospitalización por kobe es
una buena noticia porque sería una
herramienta terapéutica más y además de
eso accesible en todos los países de la
región para enfrentar el coi 19 doctor
le pregunto por otro estudio otra
investigación que ha demostrado que el
kobe 19 ha acelerado la aparición de
superbacterias y también está
disminuyendo en algunos pacientes el
efecto que tienen los antibióticos que
se dice al respecto
si definitivamente hay dos momentos en
la pandemia uno donde se usó demasiado
los antibióticos recordemos que al
principio se le atribuye un efecto
antiviral a un antibiótico a las
intromisiones y se usó
indiscriminadamente eso generó un
problema de resistencia y por el otro
lado cuando ya hemos los pacientes
gravemente enfermos se usó un uso
excesivo de los antibióticos que genera
esto bacterias resistentes a esos
antibióticos que usamos tradicionalmente
se vuelven resistentes y eso disminuye
la posibilidad de opciones terapéuticas
en un futuro es una gran preocupación
para la comunidad médica esta emergencia
de bacterias multidrogorresistente es no
por el coach sino porque estas bacterias
quedan circulando y pueden infectar a
las personas en un tiempo cercano
entonces el llamado es hacer un uso
apropiado los antibióticos y tener mucha
monitoría acerca estas bacterias
multidrogorresistente es realmente es un
gran problema médico que nos vamos a
enfrentar en la post pandemia doctor por
último quiero que hablemos de un estudio
realizado por varias universidades de
eeuu y del reino unido que encontraron
que uno tercio de los siervos que
analizaron en el estado de iowa en
estados unidos presentan la infección
del sars cop 2 es decir el kobe 19 o el
coronavirus que el riesgo representa
esto para la humanidad
sí es muy importante la identificación
de otros reservorios recordemos que el
sars code o preferentemente el
reservorio ser humano se describió al
principio de la pandemia los bisontes y
ahora con este reporte de los ciervos y
la importancia es que si estos animales
permanecen con inóculos virales se
pueden replicar o hacer variaciones o
linajes y que pueden re infectar a los
humanos por eso esa monitoría en la
medicina veterinaria de otros
reservorios es muy importante estamos
esperando cuáles son los resultados
finales de este estudio si hay divina g
son mutaciones que se deben de estar en
algún tipo de animales como en estos
ciervos porque habría que tomar medidas
y moneditas adicionales y en este
momento se están evaluando otro gran
grupo de animales a ver si hay algún
reservorio adicional para éste
coronavirus recordemos que el coronario
se infecta naturalmente al ganado a las
aves y a otras especies animales y por
eso se debe mantener en monitoría pues
para que no haya este tipo de mutaciones
y nos afecte nuevamente
doctor y yo dejo lo mejor para el final
usted esta semana presentó en la ciudad
de bogotá en colombia un libro titulado
20 meses dentro del cob y 19 relatos de
un infectólogo de que se trata de donde
viene la idea y donde lo pueden adquirir
nuestros televidentes
este es un libro que nació pues de toda
esta experiencia en todo el código y ha
sido también la amable y la generosidad
de nuestra teleaudiencia
el equipo de france 24 que me
permitieron pues relatar todo lo que
hemos visto en la pandemia tanto desde
el punto vista médico como desde el
punto de vista de la pedagogía social
tan necesaria es un libro que hace un
relato de las diferentes escenas que
vivimos en el código de la información
de la desinformación y de todo lo que se
trabajó ese es un trabajo que hicimos
con mucho amor pues para todos nosotros
y para dejar un testimonio de la lucha
que tuvimos durante la pandemia y en lo
que nos vamos a enfrentar en un futuro
este es un libro que se consigue en una
página de internet que se llama infectó
web puntocom y estaría muy complacido de
que nuestra teleaudiencia la pudiera
compartir doctor pues en nombre de todo
el equipo de kobe 19 la semana en
américa y del equipo de france 24 lo
felicitamos por este logro importante
material de referencia de consulta para
tener un panorama de lo que hemos vivido
a lo largo de estos años de pandemia
kobe 19 muchas gracias por acompañarnos
hoy también en el programa en la región
de las américas más de 550 millones de
personas han recibido el esquema
completo de vacunación contra el hobbit
19 aún así los contagios están en
aumento en nuestra región eeuu es el
país con la mayor cantidad de contagios
y decesos por kobe 19 allí la vacunación
también está avanzando muy lentamente
ariana villacorta nos cuenta más más de
la mitad de la población de américa ya
está vacunada contra el cob y 19 de
acuerdo con la organización panamericana
de la salud en norteamérica el 54% de la
población ha sido inoculadas con el
esquema completo y 20 países en las
américas ya inmunizaron con las dosis
correspondientes al 40 por ciento de su
población total hoy hemos alcanzado un
hito importante la mitad de las personas
en américa latina y el caribe han sido
vacunados completamente contra el kobe
19 según esta misma institución las
islas cayman puerto rico chile
saba uruguay y canadá son los países con
el índice de vacunación más alto de la
región de las américas por cada 100
personas sin embargo menos del 20 por
ciento de los ciudadanos en guatemala
jamaica y san vicente y las granadinas
ha recibido el esquema completo mientras
que la cobertura de vacunación sigue
siendo de un solo dígito en nicaragua y
haití en la última semana en el
continente los nuevos casos se han
reducido en un 5% y el número de muertes
nuevas ha bajado en un 17% en algunos de
los países más poblados como eeuu brasil
y colombia así como en países de
centroamérica el número de casos nuevos
se estabilizó mientras que hay países en
los que se está presenciando un aumento
en los contagios
incluso donde la tasa de vacunación es
alta en nuestra región varios países
como argentina uruguay ecuador
guatemala y paraguay están notificando
alzas abruptas en la detección de
infecciones fármacos resistentes que
seguramente contribuyeron al alza en la
mortalidad que hemos visto durante la
pandemia en los pacientes hospitalizados
según carissa etienne la directora de la
organización panamericana de la salud
esto es probablemente resultado del uso
indebido y sin precedentes de
antimicrobianos para tratar el kobe 19
como por ejemplo de la ivermectina y la
cloroquina que se encuentran entre los
medicamentos que han demostrado ser
ineficaces contra el coronavirus para
frenar los contagios algunos países como
colombia ya empezaron a exigir el pase
sanitario para ingresar a espacios
públicos algo que perú también hará
próximamente
entretanto se espera que 3.5 millones de
dosis de la vacuna anti cobit lleguen a
la región en los próximos días
veamos a continuación cómo avanza la
vacunación en el continente americano
les presento a continuación el
porcentaje de la población que ya tiene
el esquema completo comienzo con
groenlandia en el norte de nuestro
continente y el 65,5 52% de la población
ya tiene el esquema completo bahamas el
32 31% la república dominicana el 50 31%
la isla de curazao el 57,11 por ciento y
finalmente la isla de aruba en el caribe
el 70 y 2,40 por ciento
la farmacéutica pfiezer anunció que
permitirá a los fabricantes de
medicamentos genéricos elaborar su
píldora antiviral experimental contra el
cob y 19 en cerca de 95 países de
ingresos bajos pese a su interés de
hacer más asequible este medicamento la
farmacéutica es señalada a nivel
internacional de contribuir en la
desigualdad en la repartición de vacunas
veamos
una nueva herramienta contra el co bit
19 el gigante farmacéutico
estadounidense faisal firmó este martes
un acuerdo que facilitaría el acceso
mundial a su píldora antiviral un pacto
con medicine es patent pool permitirá
distribuir sus licencias a ciertos
fabricantes de medicamentos genéricos
para que produzcan sus propias versiones
de la píldora y el medicamento fácil de
producir es un fármaco oral por lo que
también es potencialmente fácil de tomar
y no necesita ser tomado en un entorno
hospitalario esto significa que si se
aprueba podría contribuir en gran medida
salvar vidas en los países de ingresos
bajos y medios en berlín con cánceres
los 95 países del acuerdo abarcan casi
el 53 por ciento de la población mundial
mayoritariamente en acciones de renta
baja y media-baja y mientras la pandemia
se mantenga como una emergencia
internacional según la organización
mundial de la salud kaiser renunciará a
los ingresos por derechos de patente
objetivos el objetivo básicamente es
evitar que la gente vaya al hospital o
tenga casos graves lo que significa que
hay que tomar el medicamento
días después de los primeros síntomas
first entonces el nuevo tratamiento está
pendiente de aprobación en distintos
países pero el fármaco oral podría ser
una prometedora arma en países con
acceso limitado a las vacunas muchos
países de renta media alta como
argentina brasil china malasia y
tailandia donde existe una capacidad de
producción de genéricos establecida
están excluidos del territorio de
licencias falso que ya comercializa una
de las vacunas más eficaces contra el
cob y afirmó que en su ensayo clínico la
píldora redujo en un 89% la posibilidad
de hospitalización o muerte de los
adultos con riesgo de enfermedad grave
la empresa anunció que espera fabricar
al menos 50 millones de tratamientos
para finales de 2022
y vamos a hablar de colombianos ponemos
en contexto demos un vistazo a las
cifras de este país suramericano allí el
total de los casos contabilizados de
kobe 19 desde el inicio de la emergencia
ya supera los 5 millones 40 mil los
fallecidos ya superan los 127 mil 900 en
colombia' la variante predominante es la
delta que representa el 84 por ciento de
los casos le sigue la variante muy con
el 14 punto 29 por ciento y finalmente
la variante gamma ronda el 2% de los
casos en cuanto a la vacunación las
personas con el esquema completo ya
alcanzan el 45 por ciento de la
población con al menos una dosis
inoculada al 21% eso nos da un total del
66 por ciento de los habitantes de
colombia con algún tipo de inmunización
contra el cob y 19
vamos a conocer más detalles de la
situación de colombia maría clara calle
desde la redacción de france 24 en
bogotá nos tiene más información hola
maría clara gracias por acompañarnos hoy
en el programa y comienzo preguntándole
por la medida del pase sanitario en este
caso en colombia lo conocen como carné
de vacunación cómo ha sido recibida la
medida y en qué caso debe ser usada
santiago el gobierno de colombia dispuso
de esta medida de manera obligatoria
para todos los mayores de 18 años y es
necesaria para acceder a lugares como
bares restaurantes cines conciertos
escenarios deportivos museos entre otros
lugares públicos a partir del 30 de
noviembre también cobijará a los mayores
de 12 años de esta manera las
autoridades buscan estimular la
inmunización y apoyar la reactivación
económica pues permiten el aforo de
asistentes completo esto para el sector
comercial que debido al confinamiento
presentó cuantiosas pérdidas económicas
sin embargo en la sociedad colombiana la
medida ha generado opiniones divididas
entre quienes lo ven como una manera de
hacerle cerco al virus y otros que
piensan que es una manera del gobierno
de forzar la inoculación entre quienes
no quieren recibir una vacuna pero hay
sectores que mostraron su preocupación
debido a que la norma deja las
responsabilidades a propietarios y
administradores de los establecimientos
ante posibles falsificaciones del
documento maría clara también hay un
leve aumento en el número de casos la
ocupación de las salas de cuidado
intensivo en diferentes regiones del
país que dicen las autoridades
colombianas
a lo largo de la semana de los casos han
ido aumentando de hecho el jueves el
ministerio de salud reportó más de 2 mil
121 nuevos casos de contagios y 51
fallecidos esta es la cifra más alta de
la última semana las regiones donde se
han registrado más casos son el
departamento de antioquia con más de 400
contagios nuevos esto todos los días
allí las autoridades han expresado su
preocupación ante un posible cuarto pico
de contagio para el mes de diciembre que
sigue en las ciudades de barranquilla
bogotá que es la capital el departamento
del valle del cauca y el departamento de
santander en el nororiente colombiano y
para terminar mal aclara que otras
medidas se mantienen allí vigentes en
este país que dicen las autoridades
sobre la permanencia de estas medidas
en colombia se mantienen las medidas
básicas como el uso obligatorio de la
mascarilla en espacios públicos también
el lavado de manos y el distanciamiento
social siguen siendo normas
indispensables ahora a esto se suma la
exigencia del carné de vacunación con la
que se busca evitar un nuevo
confinamiento que lleve a un cierre
parcial o total de la economía por eso
para muchos de los colombianos la
normalidad ya regresó al haber retomado
la presencialidad de sus trabajos clases
y otras actividades esto va acompañado
de un plan de vacunación que ya permite
a los mayores de 50 años acceder a la
dosis de refuerzo por otra parte desde
la casa de nariño el palacio de gobierno
informó que extenderá el decreto de
emergencia sanitaria por el kobe 19 esto
hasta el 30 de noviembre
muchas gracias maya clara por este
reporte desde la sala de redacción de
france 24 en bogotá en colombia vamos a
cambiar de tema los últimos dos años el
mundo ha vivido y ha enfrentado también
los retos que ha traído la pandemia como
el confinamiento y las restricciones
pero recientemente
ante el aumento de los casos de manera
alarmante particularmente en europa
muchas de las medidas han sido
direccionada a un grupo de personas en
particular estamos hablando de los no
vacunados quienes según la ms son uno de
los factores que ha llevado al
incremento de los casos de contagio
entre otras razones más veamos el
informe de pedro ruiz
confinamiento si restricciones son dos
palabras que se han convertido de uso
cotidiano durante estos dos años que el
mundo ha vivido en pandemia pero en las
últimas semanas se han vuelto a cobrar
relevancia no sólo por el nuevo aumento
de contagios en europa sino hacia que el
grupo de personas están enfocadas estas
medidas los no vacunados algunos países
europeos han ordenado aplicar algunas de
estas restricciones a las personas que
aún no han recibido algunas dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 medidas que
además de avivar las protestas sociales
han generado un debate sobre el que la
organización mundial de la salud puso el
reflector después esto plantea problemas
reales sobre las libertades civiles
problemas reales sobre las libertades
sobre los derechos humanos y es algo que
los gobiernos deben considerar con mucho
cuidado
pero en este contexto en el continente
americano cuáles son las restricciones a
las que se deben someter los no
vacunados en principio hay que decir que
a la fecha aún no hay políticas tan
drásticas como las que se aplican en
europa en colombia por ejemplo desde el
pasado 15 de noviembre se implementó la
medida que obliga a las personas a
presentar el carné de vacunación en
eventos masivos o lugares de
entretenimiento como museos bares y
restaurantes van a estar acá más de 45
mil personas es muy bueno que vean el
certificado por lo menos de las vacunas
me siento amenazado me siento
discriminado me siento apartado me
siento violentado porque
alentada a un establecimiento donde
muchas personas se me gana y puede
acertar porque nos han vacunado en
brasil los no vacunados podrían ser
despedidos por sus empleadores salvo que
tengan una condición de salud que les
impida ser inmunizados además los
eventos deportivos como el fútbol están
reservados sólo para las personas
vacunadas normativa que le impide al
presidente brasileño reconocido por
minimizar las consecuencias de la
pandemia los beneficios de la vacunación
asistir a un partido de la liga local
porque porque un carné de vacunación yo
quiero ver el juego del santos y ellos
me dicen que tengo que estar vacunado
cómo es eso tengo más anticuerpos que
aquellos que están vacunados yo confío y
tomó acción mientras que en chile el
llamado pase de movilidad permite
mayores libertades a los vacunados y
quienes no cuenten con el certificado
están obligados a respetar algunas
restricciones como el aforo en lugares
públicos y contar con una prueba pcr
negativa para hacer viajes inter
regionales pero ante la amenaza de un
nuevo incremento en los casos sobre todo
en la población no vacunada las
autoridades sanitarias chilenas han
advertido que en un futuro está personas
podrían ser objetivos de mayores
restricciones
la ciudad de río de janeiro en brasil
anunció esta semana que no tiene
personas contagiadas con kobe 19
hospitalizadas una noticia muy positiva
para este país que es uno de los más
afectados por la pandemia de kobe y 19 a
nivel mundial vamos a conversar entonces
con valeria sakon en nuestra
corresponsal en ese país suramericano
para conocer más detalles hola valeria
como siempre un gusto tenerte en el
programa comencemos por esas cifras 0
pacientes hospitalizados en río de
janeiro como lo lograron
la ciudad de río de janeiro está de
enhorabuena esta semana ha recibido el
alta el último paciente de kobe que
estaba internado en el hospital de
referencia para esta enfermedad han sido
casi 20 meses de pandemia con más de
15.000 hospitalizados pero ahora con el
76% de la población adulta totalmente
vacunada poco a poco la ciudad recupera
la normalidad las mascarillas ya no son
obligatorias en la calle e incluso las
escuelas de samba han retomado los
ensayos multitudinarios además hay un
dato interesante que demuestra la
eficacia de la vacuna en las últimas
semanas la gran mayoría de los pacientes
hospitalizados no estaban vacunados el
42 por ciento o solamente había recibido
una dosis el 39 por ciento y esos datos
se repiten también en otros estados
federados como el distrito federal donde
se encuentra brasilia una noticia
alentadora valeria sin duda alguna y
también en brasil pasa a ser parte de la
lista de países que comenzó a inocular
la tercera dosis para todos los adultos
esta semana el ministerio de salud de
brasil ha anunciado que aplicará la
tercera dosis de vacuna a toda la
población adulta y lo hará con un
intervalo de cinco meses en vez de los
seis meses anunciados inicialmente
eso es cualquier persona adulta que haya
tomado la segunda dosis hace más de
cinco meses puede acudir a un centro de
salud y recibirá esta dosis de refuerzo
que está pensada precisamente para
evitar una tercera ola de contagios y
evitar por lo tanto el escenario que se
está produciendo en muchos países
europeos que están enfrentando su cuarta
ola esa dosis de refuerzo puede ser de
cualquier laboratorio se ha aprobado de
hecho la vacunación cruzada es decir que
si una persona toma una dosis de dos de
un laboratorio puede tomar la tercera de
otro laboratorio esta semana también
hemos sabido que brasil ha superado a
los eeuu en el porcentaje de población
totalmente vacunada de esta forma se
suma a otros 55 países que también han
superado los sonidos con casi el 60% de
la población adulta totalmente bajo nada
a nivel nacional valeri hablemos de
cifras a lo largo del año 2020 brasil
tuvo récord absoluto de muertes por
causa del cob y 19 cuáles fueron esos
números ampliemos más
los datos oficiales muestran que 2020
fue el año más mortífero de la historia
reciente para brasil un millón y medio
de vidas perdidas de ellas
196.000 por causa del coronavirus y esta
cifra coincide con el cálculo hecho por
el consorcio independiente de la prensa
que es un grupo de medios de
comunicación que el año pasado empezó a
hacer una contabilidad independiente en
un momento recordamos cuando el gobierno
de jair bolsonaro empezó a ocultar los
datos oficiales sobre los fallecimientos
por el cob y además el año pasado
también bajaron un 4,7 por ciento los
nacimientos no es la primera vez pero sí
es un dato muy malo en esta década sólo
hubo un dato peor en 2016 cuando brasil
enfrentó la epidemia del virus y acá y
los nacimientos bajaron un 5 por ciento
y también han bajado las bodas un 26% el
año pasado aunque hay que decir que
ahora con la reapertura de todo en
brasil poco a poco se retoman la vida y
se empiezan también a celebrar más bodas
muchas gracias valeria por este reporte
desde la ciudad de río de janeiro vamos
a cambiar de tema europa sigue siendo el
foco de la pandemia en este momento esta
semana la o ms anunció que el viejo
continente es el único en el mundo en el
que han aumentado allí el número de
muertes por kobe 19 en la última semana
países como austria y letonia han vuelto
a instaurar la medida del confinamiento
eslovenia también está estudiando la
posibilidad de confinar nuevamente a los
ciudadanos mientras que alemania ha
superado sus propios récords de contagio
diario superando los 53 mil casos por
día los no vacunados y la baja
vacunación son algunos de los factores
veamos
vuelven a sonar las alarmas por el
hobbit 19 en europa ya que según la oms
ese es el único continente del mundo en
el que están aumentando las muertes por
el virus con un incremento del 5 por
ciento en la última semana en alemania
con la tasa de incidencia y la ocupación
de las unidades de cuidados intensivos
al alza el gobierno de angela merkel
advirtió de la gravedad de la situación
y la situación actual de la pandemia es
dramática no puedo decirlo de otra
manera la cuarta ola golpeó a nuestro
país con toda su fuerza y aunque no hay
más fundamento legal para la situación
de emergencia nacional pandémica no
tengo ninguna duda que nos encontramos
en medio de tal situación de emergencia
en francia han optado por pedir a las
empresas que impulsen el teletrabajo y a
pesar de mostrarse optimista el
ejecutivo galo no descarta aplicar
medidas si es necesario
y yo sigo siendo cautelosamente
optimista y repito cautelosamente
optimista los datos y los modelos que
tenemos el instituto pasteur muestran
que con el nivel actual de vacunación
probablemente tenemos las herramientas
para limitar el impacto de la quinta ola
de rifas
mientras que en austria siguen
registrando récord de casos a pesar de
la imposición del confinamiento para los
no vacunados desde el lunes una polémica
medida que se está debatiendo en toda
europa por lo que denuncian es una
restricción de libertades y para algunos
su cuestionada efectividad
no se puede diferenciar a las personas
de esa manera crear dos clases sociales
creo deberíamos volver a un cierre total
y que eso no es factible
si la situación no mejora ms y ha
advertido que el continente podría
llegar a sumar 500.000 muertes más por
el virus hasta febrero
veamos entonces cuáles son los países en
europa que están en una situación más
crítica ante el aumento de casos de kobe
19 austria como lo mencionábamos anunció
que volverá al confinamiento por 20 días
alemania con récords de contagio diario
y también allí las autoridades están
contemplando la posibilidad de imponer
restricciones rusia allí están con una
baja tasa de vacunación reportaron más
de 1200 fallecidos en un día la
república checa anunció restricciones
para los no vacunados hasta el mes de
febrero en sintonía está también su
vecina eslovaquia que busca hacer un
bloqueo a los no vacunados una medida
muy criticada por el gobierno ucrania
después de superar los 80 mil fallecidos
en 24 horas a lo largo de esta semana el
gobierno en kiev estudia imponer
restricciones italia también evalúa el
toque de queda para los no vacunados
mientras que bélgica impuso nuevamente
el uso de la mascarilla y el teletrabajo
en el reino unido- está avanzando una
versión mucho más contagiosa de la
variante delta y en hungría hay una baja
tasa de vacunación el 40% de los
húngaros no ha recibido ni una dosis de
alguna vacuna polonia reportó cifra
récord de más de 24.000 casos diarios de
contagio y también están estudiando
restricciones portugal cuenta con una
alta tasa de vacunación pero por
prevención el gobierno luso impondrá las
restricciones que va a anunciar
próximamente letonia está en
confinamiento desde hace tres semanas y
sigue reportando récords de fallecidos
de 79 muertos por día
y brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente brevemente les cuento
que costa rica registró durante esta
semana la menor cantidad de casos de
kobe 19 en lo que va corrido del 2021
con mil 723 nuevos casos se trata de una
disminución del 32% en comparación con
la semana o la primera semana del mes de
noviembre cuando reportaron
2500 casos méxico anunció que vacunar a
menores de edad con edades comprendidas
entre los 15 y los 17 años sin
comorbilidades éstos después de recursos
presentados por varias familias e
impugnaciones ante el gobierno
previamente estaba permitida la
vacunación para los menores de edad pero
que tuvieran algunas enfermedades como
por ejemplo diabetes y brevemente les
cuento que todos los mayores de 60 años
5 morbilidad es que residen en la ciudad
de lima la capital del perú y también en
su puerto ubicado en la ciudad del
callao ciudades que conforman una sola
zona urbana pueden recibir la tercera
dosis o refuerzo así lo determinaron las
autoridades y pronto esta medida se va a
otras ciudades del país
voluntarios italianos están participando
en una serie de pruebas en la habana en
la capital de cuba allí están estudiando
cómo se comportan las vacunas locales
este estudio busca determinar si la
tercera dosis de la vacuna llamada
soberana plus tiene algún tipo de
reacción o si tiene la inmunidad
necesaria entre personas que no hayan
sido inoculadas con dosis de estas
vacunas cubanas en total son 35
voluntarios italianos con pauta completa
de vacunación o que están sin vacunar o
que ya tuvieron kobe 19 y se recuperaron
satisfactoriamente
la pandemia de un desafío por toda la
humanidad no puede ser una necesidad de
aquel pueblo de otro pueblo yo me vacuno
otra vez esto no tiene vacunas es una
necesidad del cual todos tenemos que
responder a la situación y en esta
situación yo pienso que la vacuna cubana
su capacidad de respuesta es algo
extremadamente interesante es por esta
razón que solo aquí para averiguar si
efectivamente como parece soberana plus
puede ser una respuesta universal a la
necesidad de vacunarse puede ser una
respuesta universal a la necesidad de
vacuna a nivel
una vez más reafirmar la seguridad de
este producto extremadamente seguro con
muy pocas reacciones adversas y
reafirmar también la inmunogenicidad de
la vacuna
específicamente en su posibilidad de
proteger contra diferentes variantes del
virus ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el hobby 19
destacadas en redes la despedida de año
en el emblemático times square en la
ciudad de nueva york será solo permitida
para los vacunados así lo dieron a
conocer las autoridades de la gran
manzana quienes indicaron que a todas
las personas mayores de 5 años deberán
presentar allí una prueba de vacunación
realizada antes del 16 de diciembre y
quienes no tengan alguna vacuna deben
presentar alguna prueba de pcr negativa
realizada 72 horas antes de este evento
eeuu también busca producir mil millones
de dosis de vacunas
rn a más al año todo esto para atender a
la pandemia de kobe 19 y también a
futuras amenazas además de garantizar
más dosis para eeuu también le permite a
este país ayudar a otras naciones que no
pueden acceder fácilmente a las vacunas
y vamos a finalizar con este artículo
elaborado por nuestros colegas de radio
francia internacional las tres grandes
falacias de facer sobre la vacuna contra
el kobe 19 según lo indica amnistía
internacional esto después de haber
realizado una investigación que
determinaron allí en esta investigación
de este organismo internacional que la
farmacéutica ha hecho declaraciones
engañosas sobre su verdadero compromiso
de equidad en la distribución de vacunas
mientras continúa enviando a los países
más ricos la mayoría de las dosis a
estos países que tienen más poder
económico
y con esto llegamos al final de kobe 19
la semana en américa recuerde sigan
cuidando
usando el tapabocas y también lavándose
las manos y guardando el distanciamiento
social nos vemos la próxima semana hasta
entonces
[Música]